[Musique]
johnny jarre bonjour bonjour bonjour aux
fruits à l'aise aux fouilles à l'est et
à toute la martinique alors vous êtes
candidat de l'alliance matnik dans la
troisième circonscription de fordo celle
de forme france et vous êtes aussi
adjoint au maire de fort de france
qu'est ce qui motive votre candidature
je suis candidat pour aider la ville de
fort de france et de la martinique je
suis candidat pour poursuivre le travail
du député serge letchimy faire entendre
la voix de fort-de-france et de la
martinique à l'assemblée nationale et je
suis aussi candidat avec bénédicte di
gironimo de façon à en complément c'est
avant tout une religion si ma suppléante
pardon de façon être dans la mise en
oeuvre de projets à la fois validé par
les fouilles à l'aise
celui de didier laguerre maire de fort
de france mais aussi par les
martiniquais est celui de cette chimie
en 2021 donc je veux en équipe travaille
et la cohérence d'une mise en projet
dans ma fonction de parlementaire est en
discussions avec les ministères et le
gouvernement vous n'êtes pas le candidat
du puck man tinker de le candidat de la
mairie pas du tout je suis le candidat
d'abord des électrices et des électeurs
donc les administrés bien sûr le four de
france qui décideront maintenant je
porte un projet est donc le projet il a
déjà été validé par les martiniquais par
les fouilles à l'aise eux mêmes
donc c'est clair que je suis d'abord au
service des citoyens
des fouilles à l'aise et défauts et
haley qui vont directement choisir leurs
représentants mais aussi des matinées
quasi des martiniquais mais pour porter
un projet pas une question d'hommes
maintenant il ya un projet et il ya
aussi une équipe c'est à dire je serai
pas parlementaire isolé dans quel état
d'esprit vous êtes parce qu'on a
l'impression que cette candidature c'est
quand même la candidature du tous les
dangers
pas du tout je pense qu'il faut garder
de la sérénité de l'humilité des cons à
la proximité la confiance et le travail
qui est fait puisque j'ai une solide
expérience politique de plus de 22 ans
notamment à fort de france et
particulièrement à fort de france je
sais que ce que nous portons aujourd'hui
représentent la réalité des souffrances
quotidiennes et martiniquais ya cinq
grandes orientations que je porte bien
sur la première il s'agit pour moi de
faire progresser le lien social
la justice sociale et l'éducation pour
les fouilles à l'aise les foyalais et la
martinique le deuxième à deuxième grande
orientation c'est justement
accompagner les acteurs du développement
humain économique écologique pour bâtir
une prospérité au service de l'humain
comment l'elysée au nom je vais y
arriver laissez moi simplement te mets
en préservant et en valorisant nos
milieux naturels le troisième grand axe
troisième devant d'orientation c'est
justement appuyer les politiques
publiques de la ville de fort de france
et de la cité m la quatrième grande
orientation concerne dans la république
française plus de responsabilités
locales le droit à l'initiative le droit
à la différence les conditions
d'expression et d'épanouissement de
notre personnalité martiniquaise et de
notre identité est aussi notre
intégration dans notre géographie
cordiale que la caraïbe et enfin le
dernier gros taxe que je porte s'agit il
s'agit pour moi véritablement
d'améliorer la senti le cadre de vie les
déplacements aussi bien intérieurs
qu'extérieurs mais aussi le mieux vivre
le mieux-être collectif dans les
quartiers à fort de france en martinique
et pour revenir à votre question sur le
point 2 comment agir concrètement je
prends un exemple il faut absolument
investir aujourd'hui en martinique donc
là c'était mettre en place un plan
d'investissement et moi j'ai un travail
à faire parce qu'il ya un des outils qui
peut être créateurs d'activités
créateurs de richesses et de créateurs
d'emploi et de pouvoir d'achat ce sont
les entreprises donc l'idée c'est de
proposer une loi d'orientation qui leur
permettent d'avoir des vêtements une
partie de leurs dettes dans un plan
d'apurement pourrait être effacé le
reste est allé et puis une exonération
des charges fiscales et sociales sous
les 5 prochaines années pour alléger les
charges des entreprises et en
contrepartie les aider à recruter pour
la professionnalisation dif permettent à
ce que cela génère bien sûr l'activité
de la richesse et aussi de l'emploi
c'est un des sujets majeurs il y à
d'autres sujets comme développer des
filières d'innovation au niveau de la
biodiversité
et au niveau également des ressources en
énergies renouvelables mais aussi au
niveau maritime puisque ce sont nos
ressources naturelles en trente secondes
on 30 40 secondes qu'est ce que vous
avez à dire aux ses lectures pour lui et
pour les convaincre
complètement ma cadiot nous toujours là
l'épisode fort-de-france déjà épi
martinique - là pour faire à travers une
équipe et peep bénédicte 10 juin au
niveau épisode à condition que d'autres
d'ici du bas nous faut cela jodias faut
que nous basons ans les sports en
l'avenir pour nos enfants nous unit et
le cadre de vie et un mieux vivre
ensemble non déterminé et engagé pour
travailler épisode on vous demande de
vous mobiliser autour du projet que vous
avez déjà validé mais qui sera complétée
autour d'une équipe et autour d'une
dynamique d'engagement de proximité au
service des fouilles à l'aise des
fouilles à l'est et les martiniquais
johnny hazzard je vous remercie merci à
vous
[Musique]